you know you got you got nice color skin
what color would you say that is
my color
oh Sage they have the worst land
possible
[Music]
but they outsmart everybody
the land had oil on it
Black Gold
money flows freely here now I do love
that money sir
where are you
this wealth should come to us
their time is over
it's going to be another tragedy
when this money started coming
we should have known it came with
something else
learn like buzzards circling our people
we're still Warriors
[Music]
kill these white men who
man who I need you here I am right here
you've got to take back control of your
home
I was uh sent down from Washington DC to
see about these murders
see what about him
see who's doing it
[Applause]
[Music]
where are we
[Applause]
expect in America to make all this go
away
[Music]
you know they don't happen anymore
[Applause]
[Music]
all right